this is the end of human history the end
of human dominated history history will
continue with somebody else in control
in five years they'll be a technology
that can make decisions independently
and that can create new ideas
independently maybe they'll be nice
maybe they'll solve cancer and climate
change but we are not sure I'm tending
to think of it more in in terms of of
really an alien invasion an alien Fleet
of spaceships coming from planet Zircon
or whatever with soup with highly
intelligent beings this is what we are
facing except that the aliens are not
coming in spaceships from planet Zircon
that are coming from the laboratory if
the humans are divided among themselves
and are in an arms race then it's
because it becomes almost impossible to
contain this alien intelligence